I've always my entire life have valued
friends over everything so I've learned
a lot now I have a lot of tools I've
learned a lot of things in recovery but
I have I have like the same friends that
I've met when I was in third grade like
things come and go the one thing that
has to like stay constant in my life is
friendship so I nurtured those things I
nurtured I made sure no matter what
happened in my life I would take trips I
would call and when we say love we
usually tend to refer to romantic
relationships but for me I was like love
is for me like man love me loving
another man telling you know calling a
guy to tell him how much I love him if I
didn't have that I would be dead right
now I can tell you three stories right
now where if I didn't have a guy in my
life that was like we're not doing this
Dave like I would I would be dead right
now you did reach a point where you were
receptive to some level of self-care or
listening to their friends were trying
to tell you barely receptive but but
enough to save your life